I know what welcome to this video
yeah this rating in sucks yeah I just
tried with a warm-up game and I just
lost that like a complete idiot check so
I don't know I really have to
get focused up or something I'm really
absolutely not focused and I don't know
why exactly it's not like I feel badly
or anything I just like I need a see
absolutely nothing so this is a
theoretical line in the scotch and I
have played a couple of times it's a
it's it's usually okay for black it's a
bit of a space disadvantage but some
active ideas now f5 is maybe on okay so
let's let's check out five looks like
the right move but I returned its kids
really strange sometimes sometimes
you're in a situation like where
wherever your complete feel for the game
is on zero then that sometimes happens
to me it gets better after a bit of time
but for some reason I have to go through
that absolute this absolute rubbish
phase here I can take on Genji three I
mean that then I be able to see even in
my current state of a form that must
work if not something is really off here
I mean check so don't don't tell me this
is not great for black yeah then I'm
kind of losing all faith and everything
okay so okay
and now the night here is not great that
cannot possibly go to I got to have
three the night it was going to be
possible
Knight to Knight f5 all of a sudden this
isn't I'm not winning a merely why why
it looks like it completely wrong white
I do have to play
no wouldn't work it just goes back it's
not actually threatening to move any of
those pieces right I mean you can go to
the tool like Bishop d2 192 it no does
that really do much if I now go here
you cannot play King c2 we should be
three not sure that that that really
does something but I can go back right
we should be six threatening threatening
stuff so let's go here maybe can somehow
survive this
I need to get more activity slow cannot
cannot do that much in terms of activity
but I don't see how to how to improve my
position here clear in some clear way
[Music]
it's kind of is tied down but it's not I
don't really have anything great
available at least I don't see it so you
should back not ideal but don't see what
else to do what I what I do see is I can
if I would like the key to d3 would be
great but I don't see how that should
ever work so I'm sticking here I don't
see how I improve this like
yeah it seems that he would be happy
with the draw c6 Roxy ADA it looks I
really don't want to draw in this
position but I probably have to it's not
an illogical result in some way I see no
way to to do stuff here King e6 actually
and then that I can maybe play without
risking risking the house who create we
should be seven check and Bishop g5
I can't let Bishop g5 in this position
and then he finds it of course what what
is more a mass check that typical right
[Music]
okay my still has to win this I mean
it's not a given time warning he doesn't
even try to win
I maybe start on position check check
I'm getting the a pond I mean I can try
with the ponds I can't have to take now
I Jamie I think I'm not risking all that
much check what's a reasonable time left
check-check
check hmm getting quite active now it
was a can sander check check check
amazing check shoot my chest look
getting good check have some chance with
the time check check
yeah bloody time yeah of course no
draw-game
drawn I'm such a no word this is so
easily winning now check hey if things
don't work out they don't work out in
any way but the craziest thing is that
this position after the peace sacrifice
not winning I mean it just looks at
Rochas it is atrocious row create and he
resigns him of course I mean he has no
development whatsoever so check yeah
this is completely killing like check
check check mate one of the chick mates
yeah this is this just just not not a
real good Jackie
I mean it's enough for a draw which is
no surprise and you're so active but but
still young yeah let's see five of
courses I mean he kind of desperately at
the moment so I tried to try it's tough
it's probably to risk him check I
overlooked this move through cage was
actually possible crazy Jenny where are
threatening stuff him into bigger things
okay so that was better check didn't try
it all to win check just give me a
chance and then change it with the night
check check Jamie there there
check check check
no it was just really simple check
okay 20 seconds but check this this is
pretty easy it was kind of thing check
yeah and of course I should just play
and play the rookie and here to shear
from the side
check our technical play with no charm
is really not good
never was check I need to return to
contemplate and see it's a drone oh okay
thanks for watching